So I think the first time that I realized I needed to like tangibly do something
about it, uh,
which is the movement that'd be called American contingency outside of my own
business was when, uh,
law enforcement officers in Seattle stopped responding to certain calls
and that happened. And then they set up this Capitol Hill movement,
which became a nightmare.
And they basically allowed for disorderly conduct,
even criminal activity. That was the first time that we went, okay,
we need to do something about it. I was just in Portland, Oregon,
about four weeks ago, four weekends ago. Uh, the Portland authority, uh,
didn't respond to 60 calls in a weekend, including larceny burglary,
even reports of rape. And that's mind boggling,
like to think that you could be a law abiding citizen who pays taxes and that
there's a, you know,
a political divisiveness that takes place where it could literally
translate to you not being protected in your own community is disturbing.
This week here on the Rubin report.
And I'm doing a bunch of mini interviews with creators who have decided to
become less reliant on big tech and instead own their content,
community and livelihood with locals.com.
Joining me today is the founder of field craft survival and American
contingency. Mike Glover, welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me. It's a pleasure, Mike.
I don't know if anyone else on locals has blown this thing
up the way that you have,
you have an absolutely huge community on there.
And I think when we explain to people what it is you do on there,
they'll understand why you're on locals.
So what is the American contingency locals group all about?
So I saw an inherent need for bringing people together
without the levels of suppression that are taking place across social media.
So I do own a company called [inaudible] survival that specializes in
preparedness.
And when we started talking about preparedness in different venues,
different settings in training and mindset, audible video, et cetera,
we started realizing that even just talking about preparedness and self-defense
was getting suppressed because it seemed like it was risky or it was too
fringe,
which is surprising to me because I spent my entire life as a Greenbrae and
especially operations. I love America love freedom,
but I love passing information from lessons learned from overseas
to civilians. And so when I started doing that,
I started getting routinely suppressed by every major platform and realize we
needed to look somewhere else at the same time, uh,
socially, uh, we were having problems with, uh,
discourse and w you know,
the breakdown of law and order or politicians and forcing law and order.
And so I realized I needed to provide something that wasn't going to be
suppressed. So I reached out to locals and locals became our home.
So in essence, you guys are a community of preppers and you're,
you're kind of guiding everybody on,
on some of the tips and tricks of the trade.
And it's kind of funny because you're right. When,
when people think about prepper is the mainstream ideas, Oh,
somehow this is some sort of scary right. Wing something.
And yet we've seen in what, seven months a lockdown,
a lot of people became preppers pretty freaking quick. So you,
you must be feeling kind of good about that.
Yeah. Things have obviously changed in our society based on the pandemic,
based on, um, the, the, the drama that's taking place. But we even,
before all this was taking place,
we advocated for people to be self-reliant and that depend on the government
or institutions outside of their control to come and rescue them. You know,
our saying is you are your own first response. Well,
now with the political divisiveness causing first responders to sometimes
never respond, made us realize that, um, not only are your,
are you your own first response,
but you might have to sustain your survivability over time.
So America tendency was that movement to train, to mentor, advise,
and to provide a social network for people to come together and,
and to see it happen almost overnight.
And the engagement that we have was, uh, inspiring to me,
because I realized that maybe we are identifying a problem that the rest or a
lot of Americans are seeing today. Yeah.
It's incredible. I'm a member of the community when I've jumped in there,
just to see what the conversation's like. It's like, there's no hate there's no,
there's no anger. There's,
these are good people who are just trying to figure out how to not be so reliant
on the systems that as you, as you kind of said,
they're the systems that seemingly are failing. You know,
if you're calling cops and they're not showing up or whatever it might be, well,
then maybe you do have to take some of this into your own hands. When,
when did you get interested in all of this?
So I think the first time that I realized I needed to like tangibly do something
about it, uh,
which is the movement that we called American contingency outside of my own
business was when, uh,
law enforcement officers in Seattle stopped responding to certain calls
and that happened. And then they set up this Capitol Hill movement,
which became a nightmare.
And they basically allowed for disorderly conduct,
even criminal activity. That was the first time that we went, okay,
we need to do something about it. I was just in Portland, Oregon,
about four weeks ago, four weekends ago, uh, the Portland authority, uh,
didn't respond to 60 calls in a weekend, including larceny Burghley,
even reports of rape. And that's mind boggling,
like to think that you could be a law abiding citizen who pays taxes,
and that there's a, you know,
a political divisiveness that takes place where it could literally
translate to you not being protected in your own community is disturbing.
So that's what led us down that path. And so far,
it's been a positive experience because we, you know,
we don't tolerate fringe actors who want to, um,
have their own agendas. What we want is a positive society,
a positive community. And we don't have,
we're not going to tolerate the negative toxic, uh, divisiveness.
That's common today in our society.
And our locals, it's your community. And you can do whatever you want with it.
What kind of a censorship stuff were you dealing with on Facebook and some of
the other platforms you kind of alluded to that a moment ago?
Yeah. The biggest thing is in the end, the algorithm or the, the,
the system that is Facebook and Instagram, which we had a lot of our platforms,
even my social, my own personal social media influence on, uh,
one of the things that is a metric or a measure for understanding if you're
suppressed,
is the inability for people to organically search you in the search queue via
your name at which is, which is common, right?
Like if you look up right now and I just did this three days ago,
if you look up and T4 the word Antifa,
you will get all the organizations,
including the main pages of Antifa that aren't suppressed that populate in the
queue. If you look up Mike Glover,
you will even get the people who are pretending to be in the circle view,
but you will not get me.
And that goes for a lot of my friends who are veterans of special operations,
who are conservatives and who aren't fringe,
anybody that are just advocating for the same things we're advocating for. And,
and those things are apparent in numbers and analytics and even simple things
like search cute. Yeah.
It's incredible what they do. I mean, I got my own version of that. You know,
if you search me, it's like 10 terrible articles coming up first,
all filled with lies, or, you know,
they'll do you probably have one of these too,
when you do people also search for,
and it used to have me associated with all these people I had never heard of who
were these real fringe actors.
Eventually I was able to complain enough that I got some of that stuff fixed,
but, but in essence,
you moved over to locals and you can now do whatever you want with your
community. And,
and it seems to me that the American contingency group that you guys have a
double reason to be there because it's not just that you're preparing for the
worst in, in the real world. Uh,
but you're prepared for the worst in the digital world too.
So it has like a two-pronged piece to it.
Yeah, it definitely does what I've realized over time.
And in this short period of time that we've been on locals is that there's a
significant education process that needs to take place.
And not only advocating for platforms like locals,
but getting people to try to migrate as a good tenancy. Like I get it.
Like if a lot of your attention span is spent on a platform like Instagram,
that's going to happen because a lot of people were on it.
But if you set in place where you know that you can go suppression free onto
that platform, that's a benefit,
a benefit of having this lined out that way with the overall
goal of transferring platforms and people just staying on locals.
Like I already know my platform eventually will be shut down. I mean,
it's going to happen. And when that happens, we'll do a full migration.
But what I do is I dabble, or I put out, um,
the snippets of information via there. And then I,
I hub my content because I know it's protected. I know it's secure.
And I know it's not going to be moderated or suppressed by people who,
I don't know her, who don't agree with my message.
And that's significant for me as an influencer,
as a business owner and as somebody who wants to create a positive movement,
because now I can operate securely.
I mean,
I'm thrilled to hear a man because that's exactly why we created this thing.
It's like, it's it's tools for you to do whatever you want.
Can you talk a little bit about the business first cause American contingency
is, is the community part of this, but you had a, you had an, have a,
a pretty successful business before this that's that sort of spurred this all
on.
Yeah. So, uh, you know, I I'm I'm open about this,
but I was a special operations guy for nearly my entire life since I was 17
years old. Um, I went to war nine times.
I decided to become a CIA contractor, uh,
known as a global response staff officer. I served overseas,
did five or six additional more rotations in austere environments and
realized, uh, if I wanted to have control of my life,
I couldn't work for the government. I needed to do something different. And, uh,
in Pakistan, on my last rotation,
I decided to start Phil crowd survival also realized that there was a lot of
things that I learned in special operations and process and mindset in
rehearsal and planning and equipment that didn't have to do with specialized
tactics,
but just simple processes that civilians would benefit when looking at their
life that not only in preparedness, but just all facets of their life,
even in business. I mean,
I use simple like the five paragraph operations order that I learned as an 18
year old ranger school student.
I applied to business because it's a good way to process information and to, uh,
uh, disseminate that information in business. So feel cross survival.
I've had for about four years now. Um, and we offer training. We have podcasts,
we have free Bible information in the realm of preparedness,
trying to kind of get rid of the stereotypes associated with the prepper and
letting people know it doesn't matter what political affiliation or side of the
aisle you're on. What's, what's uh, unique about catastrophe.
It's it, it's an equal opportunity. It doesn't care what color ethnicity,
or where you come from. It's going to destroy your life all the same.
So if you're prepared, um,
you'll be better set up for success instead of failure. So that's what we do.
I'm doing it right now in Montana. Uh, I have 20 plus employees.
We subcontract and contract all over the United States, teaching civilians,
military, and law enforcement, how to be better prepared.
Yeah.
Can you tell people just like a couple of the little tips for the people that
are just sort of waiting into these waters because a lockdown, as we said,
because of seeing violence, things like that, it's interesting.
Cause I never considered myself a prepper.
We do have some emergency kits and stuff like that,
but I always liked having like a lot of canned goods in the basement or in the
pantry, like just, you know, extra water, paper towels, that kind of stuff.
I never thought of it as prepper really, but it was always like, yeah,
all hell broke loose for a couple of days. I'm in the politics world. It's like,
you can't not think of that. Um,
but I think a lot of people are just for the first time ever going, Oh,
you mean I got to not take out from a restaurant every night. You got,
I got to have some food here. I got to have some water here. What are,
what are like some of the one Oh one type things that you recommend to people
when they're just learning about this?
Yeah. I think when I look at preparedness, I look at statistical probability.
So I don't want to paint a picture like a doomsday scenario. But when you,
you know, when I was asked to two years ago on a podcast with a buddy of mine,
Mike Pfeiffer, he asked me, what is the worst case scenario? And I said,
simply the worst case scenario is a large-scale pandemic with social
disruption, chaos, or discourse. And that's exactly what we're facing right now.
And it, and it's because, uh, right now when you take and stacks,
social economic issues on top of each other, it,
it destroys the fabric restructure or in our case security that we feel.
So w what people could understand first and foremost,
is that your mindset or your,
your level of resilience in your mindset is the most important thing you could
focus on because, you know,
disastrous catastrophe come at you in different spurts of time and space.
And if it hits you in the face, like a baseball bat,
and sometimes maybe that's literally, then that's a compressed timeline,
but if you have something like a pandemic, it's a long duration timeline. Well,
ultimately, if you understand how you respond to stress,
because that's what you're reacting to,
then you have a good idea how you're going to manage the process of a disaster
or catastrophe. So it starts with mindset. So ha being healthy,
um, making your family healthy, getting sleep, taking care of your immunity,
um, eating healthy and getting exercise are basic start points that people would
never consider in a preparedness or prepper movement.
But that's the start point because when you're healthy, physically and mentally,
then you're able to make good cognitive decisions to set your self up for
success. Just a tangible takeaway for your listeners. Um,
tourniquets are one of the most important pieces of equipment that are
neglected. You could die from a, for moral or breakable bleed,
which is a large arterial bleed. In a matter of minutes,
I've seen it on the battlefield. I've even seen it in America, uh,
happened in vehicle accidents, 30,000 people a year in America,
die from car accidents.
And it's one simple $29 and 99 cents thing that you could buy online,
get trained, put it in your car, put it in your wife's purse,
put it in your pocket and carry it with you.
Because if you learn to have that lifesaving piece of equipment,
it could save your life. And it's,
and it only improves the overall life that you do have because people think that
people who are prepared are paranoid. It's the complete opposite.
When you're prepared, you're not anxious. You're not paranoid.
You're confident and living your life. Yeah.
I love that. And it's just,
it's just so obvious after the last couple months that people who thought about
some of this stuff seriously from taking care of yourself,
physically and mentally, to having some supplies and everything else, they're,
they're in a much better spot than the people that thought that the systems were
always going to exist. Um, well, listen, I was,
I was going to tell you to pimp out the American contingency community,
but I think you've done a hell of a job, uh, doing it, but,
but where can people go to, to join your locals community?
So the best link for us is American
contingency.locals.com. And that's a great start point. Um,
I also have a personal YouTube.
I'm doing this show called living your prep life,
which is a spinoff of living your best life.
But I think the best life is a prep life. Uh,
you can go to YouTube and find me under my personal was just as simply Mike
Glover, which so far, there's no suppression on that channel.
All right, well, Mike, I know my audience is going to love this,
so I want to have you on for a proper hour long, sit down.
So we'll do that over the next month or two, maybe right after the election.
Once we see what level of freak out everybody's in,
I might need some personal advice myself.
I would love that it would be an honor. All right.
Thanks, man. Well, I really appreciate it.
And truly for you guys that haven't checked out the community.
It's just unbelievable what you're doing on there.
And it's American contingency.locals.com.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.